miley has a new album out called plastic
hearts
what the [ __ ] do i know is one of the
songs it seems to me
you know it's not a great mystery anyway
that this is about your ex-husband
in a way is it because i would think in
a way
you're giving this guy too much by
writing a song about him
but i can't help it you can't in other
words it's something
it's something that burns up in your
head and you say i gotta write a lyric
to this
well it was more about i i was working i
think i actually came to see you when i
was doing nothing breaks with mark and
then right after that i went and made a
series of eps and mark was heavily
producing
that mark ronson and record
genius right genius guy super genius so
i ended up
really kind of trashing these last these
next i guess
two eps we had i released one and
trashed the other two because it was no
longer
relevant because i had this huge change
in my life
and that the music just didn't really
reflect what i was going through
anymore and and so then that's why i
wrote what the [ __ ] do i know because it
was like i had this plan you know and i
guess
we all know the saying that you know
when we when we plan
life kind of laughs in our face and says
this is what's really gonna happen and
we never really
we never really know we never could have
expected this year there's so much that
i don't know
you see this here you wanted an apology
not for me i had to leave you in your
own misery
so tell me baby am i wrong that i moved
on
and i don't even miss you that true like
in other words not that it would be you
until
i died yeah let go that's so obvious but
then you
claim you don't even spend a minute
thinking about him
but is that really true here's what's up
here's here's how i explain
songwriting and the way that i write
songs
it's like when i was a little kid i used
to love to catch fireflies you know with
my dad into the jar
and watch them all light up and when i
write a song that's what i feel like
because i feel like
i'm capturing something that is free and
that
i maybe only feel for a second it
doesn't have to be
my identity but it has to be a part of
me somewhere
what the [ __ ] do i know there's this
it's not that
it's how i feel every second of the day
it's how i felt for a moment
that works i'm sure is some sort of
protective armor and there's a sense of
myself that
does feel that way but but it's like
capturing and then
you know a record is is all these mason
jars filled with something that that
lights up that that you catch something
that's kind of
magical for a moment but it doesn't have
to it doesn't have to be you
all the time so when i see so in other
words
when you say i don't even miss you it
isn't necessarily about your husband
it was at that minute you know some some
sometimes you miss
you know people more than others and
sometimes
you know if things get easier time kind
of heals all and but that was at a time
where i felt really strong and
and then some days i don't